pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche c'est lui
les épis curieux connaissez vous
l'origine de l'expression le jeu en vaut
la chandelle
je vais vous éclairer
[Musique]
c'est une expression que l'on utilise
quand nous faisons quelque chose qui en
vaut la peine
est-ce que raconter l'origine des
expressions de la langue française par
exemple en vaut la chandelle
je pense que oui car derrière le mot se
cache toujours un peu de notre histoire
et de notre culture
mais quel rapport avec la chandelle
l'origine de cette expression remonte à
une ancienne pratique à une époque où il
n'y avait pas d'électricité ni d'écran
pour occuper les soirées dans tous les
milieux les choux modeste on se rendait
les uns chez les autres pour jouer aux
cartes ou au d et on pariait pour
l'éclairage
chacun apportait une chandelle ou verser
une contribution à l'eau même s'il ne
jouait pas pour de l'argent tous les
joueurs espéraient que les gains
compenserait le montant des bougies
l'expression c'est ensuite transposé au
théâtre l'éclairage des salles obscures
coûter très cher aux compagnies il
fallait donc que la pièce remporte du
succès qu'il y ait beaucoup de
spectateurs pour que la recette couvre
le coût de l'éclairage
c'est clair si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus merci les épis curieux pour les
plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]